[Applause]
uh
coming to you from los angeles
california
this is ea play live 2021
i'm your host wwe superstar xavier woods
aka
austin creed and we have an amazing show
for you today
we've got world premiere gameplay
exclusive first looks
including a brand new multiplayer
experience for battlefield 2042
and a few more surprises they won't even
let me tease
plus just like last year we've got some
amazing prizes to give away
so keep an eye out throughout the show
for hidden letters they'll spell out a
secret code that you'll need at the end
of the show
if you want a chance to win polaris gear
logitech gadgets and thousands of codes
for great ea games
including mass effect legendary edition
dirt
5 and more so let's get
to it
ea has long played home to fan favorite
racing titles from
need for speed to burnout to real racing
and now that the experts at codemasters
are joining the ea family
that incredible lineup just got
supercharged with the addition of
franchises like grid
dirt project cars and f1 so if you like
racing
if you like being in the driver's seat
you're gonna love what code masters has
cooked up for us today
but first let's take a quick look at
what they do best
this big
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
i
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
joining us now from london is code
masters senior game designer
becky crossdale welcome becky hey austin
hey
now i heard that you might have a little
surprise for us today
yes i do and i don't know if you can
tell austin but i am so excited
because on behalf of the entire code
masters team
this is the world premiere trailer for
grid legends
160 take 13 common
[Music]
dozens of drivers only one can become
champions
my name is yume tanaka my goal is to
become the first woman ever
to win the championship they know who i
am
i'm nathan mccain five-time grid series
world champion
it seemed to be six times and that's a
new record
if this grid legal i can build it to win
touring cars muscle cars open wheel
[Applause]
these idiots can't keep their cars on
the track
it's their problem you keep pulling up
there
that stops or you're gonna get somebody
hurt hopefully it'll be you
[Music]
bring it on baby that's why we're here
[Music]
becky this this looks incredible on top
of the gameplay in the cars and the
environments now
we've got all these characters that seem
to have different motivations i'm
already
incredibly invested it looks like you
guys are really up in the ante on
storytelling
well first and foremost the grid series
has always been about delivering
gameplay excellence
and with grid legends you are still
getting that same immersive racing
experience that you know and love
but this time we are taking things up a
notch and we're adding another layer on
top of that
we are really proud of this new story
mode well i do love a good story and i
feel like i've seen a lot of those faces
somewhere before
yet we had the absolute pleasure of
working with the incredibly talented
shitty gagwa
who plays the wonderful eric in
netflix's sex education
we also captured the entire thing using
extended reality or
xr where if you've been watching
disney's and mandalorian you will have
seen that tech in action it's what they
used to create those
incredible worlds well it sounds amazing
but this obviously isn't racing in space
right
no we are using this tech to draw you
further
into this racing experience we really
want to bring you
deeper into the grid world than ever
before
it's also been really great for our
actors because they're acting against
something that's visually there
it's not the same as green screen or
motion capture
they are stepping into our grid world
and reacting with it
it sounds great can you give us any
hints on the story or would that be
spoilers
without any spoilers um we are giving
you a classic
underdog tale we were putting you
straight into the driver's seat
right in the middle of the grid world
series where you'll be facing
off against the all dominant raven west
team
that is a team that does not like to
share the tarmac
and for the rest of the story well you
just have to wait and see
but let's talk gameplay uh we saw a new
big range of vehicles in that trailer
can you talk about those a little bit
oh yeah there are so many vehicles we
are giving you big rigs stadium trucks
drift cars
open wheelers muscle cars electric cars
we are giving you hyper cars like the
aston martin
valkyrie have you seen that car
and we are also giving you multi-class
mixed racing
which means that you can take any of
those cars and put them together on the
same track
whoa i just saw a big rig take out an
open wheeler in the trailer and i i love
it
so is there anything else that you can
tell us about grid legends
we are giving too much away there is
a ton of new stuff for the fans to sink
their teeth into
including some new modes such as boost
mode and elimination mode
we've also got some fancy new locations
like the iconic city
of moscow uh we've also got the
beautiful
city of london as well as you can drive
right past buckingham palace
or you could travel to the stunning
strada alpena and take one of our
beautiful hypercars
to its limit all right well you heard it
here first
storytelling and extended reality
mixed-class racing new modes new
locations
this is beyond exciting so becky thank
you so much for your time
no thank you austin of course all right